- Hello everyone!
So welcome to episode number
two of Unlocking Lily.
So I quit my day job
to pursue my dream in
becoming a public speaker
and you guys are all coming
along with me for the ride.
(swishing)
So my first challenge was
doing the entpresso video.
One of the most important
goals that I have
is to become a great storyteller.
I want to be able to
tell compelling stories
where people feel a little bit changed
after listening to me.
So with the entpresso video,
I'm able to take someone's message,
like Gwen Stefani's message
in finding who you are,
and use my own stories to actually be able
to give you guys a teachable lesson.
Good morning believe nation.
Today's message is find who you are,
over to you Gwen Stefani.
So when I first found out
that I will be talking about
find who you are,
I got so excited because
being on the path of
self-discovery and self-awareness
has been so important to me and
has been my focus for the past two years,
I was so, so looking
forward to actually sharing
all of that with you guys as well.
And in a weird way,
I thought
that Evan picked it on purpose for me
because he knew that it would mean a lot.
I don't know.
Maybe he did, maybe he didn't.
Maybe it was pure coincidence.
But I will find out from him.
I was really, really happy about that.
This has been a path of
mine for the past few years
and I really wanted to share my struggles,
my failures around it,
as well as to let you know that
things do get better.
Things doesn't always have to be that way.
And I wanted you to learn
from my experiences.
So knowing all that, I got
really excited on the day of.
And then it took four hours.
I don't know what it is with the camera
being in front of your face,
as soon as a camera's in front of my face
I feel like I forget everything.
So all in all, it took two days to
actually get the entire video out.
So the first day I spent two hours
going over and over what I'm going to say,
rehearsing it in my head and out loud,
and then once I got in front of the camera
it took me another two
hours to actually record
because I still get very, very nervous
when the camera's in front of my face.
Right now I feel really nervous.
And finally, finally, 28 times after
I got the first final draft.
I got really... I was so proud.
I was so proud. Oh my god,
I'm so proud of myself
and I'm going to really
send it off to Evan
and he's going to be so
impressed with me because,
you know, I did such a
good job and everything.
Which I did, which I did.
So I sent it over to him
and he gave me feedback.
So, by the way, all the
videos that you guys see
of me on his channel, he looks over.
He looks at it before
it actually goes live.
And he sends me feedback of
things I need to work on,
as well as he sends me feedback
on the things I did well as well.
So he did the same thing for this video.
But there was one thing in
particular that really just, ugh,
just got to me, was when he said
that right now you're saying
a lot of general things
and I don't feel what you're feeling.
And that's the entire thing, wasn't it.
I want to be a good storyteller
and he's not feeling what I'm feeling.
That is not the point of this.
I haven't done something
right because of that.
And then when I thought about it,
I was like okay, why, why isn't
he feeling what I'm feeling?
At that moment, I realized,
that in order to have a powerful story,
I have to be specific
about the moments in time.
about that pivotal moment
that caused me to make a
change to find out who I am.
So I suggested to rerecord
and being the really
encouraging guy that he is
he's like yeah, of course, go for it.
So the next day, after 24 hours of
reflecting what happened
to cause that change,
I decided to go in front of the camera.
And then when I did, I wasn't sure if
I wanted to share my story
specifically with you guys.
I was saying too many general things
to dance around the idea of
the real, hard hitting questions.
And the hard hitting questions was,
what caused me to change,
was I asked myself some really, really
transparent questions about myself.
I had to reveal that my job, at the time,
was making me miserable.
I had to reveal a part of me
that I wasn't so proud of,
specifically the part of me
that picked a certain job
because she thought that
money would make her happy,
you know?
Also staying with a job for so long,
knowing that you're
miserable and you're unhappy
and you have no passion for it, you know,
what would people think of me?
People are thinking like
you know better, why?
And I was so afraid of getting judged
that I didn't want to share
the specifics of my story.
And then I started thinking and I'm like
I really don't want to hurt
people's feelings either
because a lot of people that I worked with
are going to be watching my videos.
I don't want them to think that, you know,
I was miserable when I was working there
and they had something to do with it.
Or people who are doing the
same job that I was doing,
I don't want them to
think that it's a bad job,
or it makes people miserable.
The only reason why I was miserable
is because I was doing something that
I do not have passion for and that's it.
So I had to really, really
wrestle with this idea,
like do I share? Do I not share?
I don't know. Maybe I
should share another story.
And then I came to the
realization of something.
I signed a contract with you guys.
The first day when I got
in front of the camera
and I told you that I'm going to share
everything about my journey with you,
my failures, my struggles,
my joy, my celebration.
Everything.
This means this story too.
I have to tell you the story
what caused me to change.
Everything that I go
through, I can't edit it.
I can't edit certain parts of my life
and show you certain parts and
not show you certain parts.
I had to share.
And I summed up the courage to
actually do the video the next day.
So I did.
I got in front of the camera the next day
and I told my whole story around
how I found who I am today.
And I think the impact was so positive
because you guys responded to the video
in such loving, encouraging words,
and I actually really wanted to
share some of the comments
with you right now.
So the first comment
comes from Steph Reveron.
Thank you Steph!
I remember you.
You're the first one that came to
that Zumba class in December, I remember.
And, I miss you too.
So if you ever come to Toronto,
please come by Toronto Dance Salsa
and just come by and visit
and say hi or take a class.
Whatever you want to
do, just come by, okay?
I would love to see you again.
The next one comes from Paula Meneses.
Paula Meneses is one of the first people
to actually write on
my intro video as well,
so Paula, honestly, your feedback and
your encouragement and your
words mean so, so much to me.
So thank you so much Paula.
The last one comes from scholastic01.
Scholastic01, now that
you know that I struggled
really hard with whether or not
I should tell my whole
story with you guys,
your words right now made
me feel more confident
that I did the right thing.
So scholastic01, thank you
again for writing this comment.
So those are the three, but I
do have one honorable mention,
that was not on YouTube,
it's actually on Facebook.
It comes from my mom.
My mom recently discovered social media
and she's been very, very active on it
and she wrote on the video
that Evan shared on Facebook
was amazing with two smiley face emojis.
My mom is so funny and so humorous
and such a wonderful human being.
And she honestly is the
most generous person
I have ever known in my life.
She's the reason why I can give
and she taught me one
very important lesson,
is to always give without
expecting anything in return
and I will always take
it everywhere with me.
So Mom, thank you so
much. I love you. Love you
So my challenge for next week
is to research 20 inspirational speakers
that I look up to.
So right now, I have this big goal, right?
This big goal of stepping on stage and
speaking to thousands of people.
But I don't really know which
specific paths I can take.
And the truth is I can figure
everything out on my own.
I can, you know?
But it will take me a very long time.
It will take me maybe five
years, ten years, fifteen years.
I don't know.
And the truth is, a lot of times,
you and I don't have that kind of time
to actually figure things out.
So the best thing to do in that case
is actually look at people
who have gone through
what we want to go through,
whatever that mission is,
in my case, being a public speaker.
And see what their breakthroughs were
and see what their a-ha moments were
and see their mistakes so that way
we don't make the same mistakes as well.
So that's going to be all next week.
I'm going to share with you my research.
I'm going to share with you all
the breakthroughs that these people had
and how my path is going to change or
develop as a result of it.
So actually, I have a
question for you guys.
When was the last time you shared
a specific story with someone and
if you're willing, and comfortable,
I would love to see it in the comments
of what the story was.
You guys have been so
open with your stories
and I love reading it.
So the more stories you share, the better.
And I'll be looking forward in
reading all your comments below.
Once again, I am so,
so incredibly grateful
for all the wonderful comments,
the love, the encouragement, the support
that's been pouring in over
the past couple of weeks.
You guys are incredible.
I couldn't ask for more.
Thank you, thank you so much
and I will see you guys very soon.
(kissing sound)